I haven't spoken this man in a very long
time charlie weis how are you coach
I'm rich how you doing on that I'm
hanging in how you been oh just hang
hanging down here in South Florida
roughing the rough in the rough weather
you know I bet 80 85 and sunny today
you know another miserable day I bet
soak it all in charlie weis what first
first question is when did you meet Bill
Parcells the first time what did that go
down oh I you know met him officially in
1989 you know I had bumped into him at
the shore several times but jersey at
that time I was just like a fan so you
know the guy it wasn't like I went up
and talked to him but 89 I'd says when
we first met and then how did you wind
up with him on his staff how did that go
well well what happened is I was doing
some work for us some work for personnel
director tim rooney and then after after
that season that I did this work for tim
rooney lamar Leachman who is the
defensive line coach left and went to
Detroit Romeo Crennel moved to defensive
line Mike Swetman moved to the special
teams coach so they had an assistant
special team slash defensive quality
control position that they're hiring for
so he interviewed a bunch of guys and
was complaining to Tim that he can't
find the right guy and Tim said well you
had the right guy in here last all last
summer
so Tim recommended to me to Bill and
then I interviewed with Bill in the army
and then obviously you were with him
there with the Giants and then the
Patriots and then to the Jets and then
went with Belichick to the Patriots in
2000 when did you realize that Tom Brady
was pretty special for the first time
when do you recall that Charlie well we
had we had an inkling that
he had a chance as first year but he
wasn't playing at all as first year as a
matter of fact it was our fourth
quarterback and the only I think he
threw or three passes all year and he
got in one game through had one
completion for about six yards and that
that was about it but the the next year
in training camp he was fighting for
number two with damage yard who we had
picked up from Miami and he beat him out
by a hair one like tommy was clearly the
second-best guy but it was he beat him
out just by a little bit - back up -
back up drew Turner goes down Tommy goes
in you know we kind of take baby steps
as we go through the year and then about
midway through the year there was like a
turning point where we really thought we
had something special because we're
playing the Orleans we were down by 10
or 11 in the fourth quarter we came back
and scored twice you know to tie it up
we got it to overtime and on our first
offensive play and overtime New Orleans
brought a blitz that we had practiced
against multiple times in a week but we
hadn't seen once in a game and the kid
checks off he audibles throws a ball 55
yards down the field defensive pass
interference we had a picnic you know
military kicked a field goal we win the
game but the fact that mentally that a
kid would that little experience could
make a play good make a call like that
we figured we might have something
special of course later on in the
campaign you're in the Superdome in New
Orleans
Venna Terry does kick a game-winner for
the Super Bowl in a any drive that was
very famous for many reasons including
for those watching at home and the last
summer all Madden Super Bowl that they
called together Madden's like they
should take a knee here and go to
overtime because this kid you know it's
his first rodeo essentially is what he's
saying did you and Belichick have any
sense
potentially taking your foot off the
brake in that Super Bowl as you were
dialing up the place now the only ones
involved there to be honest we were
belcheck and i and tommy and drew so the
four of us sat on the sidelines we all
knew that st. Louis had had had taken
over the momentum and tied the game with
two fourth-quarter touchdowns so we
figured we should at least give a shot
we started off conservatively of course
drill was saying just go out there and
sling it like any veteran quarterback
would say but we that went out
conservative at first but then after
after we threw a little flair pass to
the left to Junior Redman and he got out
of bounds at about the 40 45 yard line
you know we became we we got work
recived
to try to get down there and get in the
field Orange then of course two more
Super Bowls came charlie weis here on
the Rich Eisen show offensive
coordinator for those Patriots
championship ears including the last
time that there were back-to-back
champions and in the NFL right here on
the Rich Eisen show and now Brady at age
42 about to be 43 is as amazing and as
relevant as ever the biggest free agent
quarterback that we've ever seen because
Peyton Manning at least when he was a
free agent he was having concerns over
how his surgically repaired neck would
do when was the last time you texted
with Tom Charlie well I mean I tech sort
of I sent him a text yesterday but I
mean I texted him last week just to say
how comical I thought it was that you
know that he that he was the story and
then he texted back to me he goes no one
knows anything and I said well I mean
not according to all the experts they
all seem to think they have the answer
and he goes well then go clean it up so
that's what I did on radio that day look
I know I didn't talk to Tommy we traded
texts he told me that no one knows
anything and believe and believe me I
would not have said that no one knows
anything if I
Shirley felt that he already knew what
he was doing I really believe that he
doesn't know what he's doing yet I think
I'm sure he's done the research because
he doesn't do diligence but but even
though he's done the research I don't
think he has any idea was still yes and
I agree with you I don't think so either
but you would definitely be expert not
only in what Brady's mindset would be
and you you got that straight from the
horse's mouth via text just a few days
ago but the tendencies of Bella check
you must know those inside and out in
the sense that Robert Kraft is not gonna
be placing any of his influence towards
the end on making something happen he's
just gonna delegate and leave this up to
Bill what what do you think Bill's
mindset is going into this whole
scenario Charlie well yeah well you
never bill even though he's well aware
of all the nuances and the ramifications
and the relationships and the legacy you
know he's a well he's well aware all
those things it's not like he's
oblivious to those but bill has a very
very unique ability to separate church
and state and by that I mean you know
when it comes down to making a business
decision he makes a business decision so
you know now as this timing is changed
with the cba vote and the tags and you
know when pre agency actually starts I
think the window has shrunk into
basically a Sunday Sunday Monday a
Sunday money really conversation you
know once the CBA is approved which I
believe it's going to be you'll know
you'll know what the rules are or if it
wasn't approved you know what the rules
are going to be right and then you know
by the by the 18th they have to have
made this decision the two of them
because after the 18th I don't think it
becomes it doesn't seem to make fit
financially once at thirty thirteen and
a half million dollar
cap it comes and then you'd have to tag
on on top of that that doesn't seem to
make much sense
yeah and that kicks in once the new
league year officially begins and and
that's what does absolutely make it as
you point out something that has to
happen before that and obviously the
window about what the rules are gonna be
has made that window even smaller as you
just pointed out charlie weis here on
the Rich Eisen show what do you make
however of the notion that Tom would
like it to be church and state he wants
to feel the love here that it's more
than just a business decision for him so
why is it a business decision
yeah specifically for New England how
that may meet Charlie what do you think
of that yeah yeah you don't know that
you don't know that and I don't know
that you know we don't know we don't
know for sure what he's thinking I mean
it's not like he's sitting here telling
people what he's thinking right I mean
the only people he's talked to you know
is his agent you know his wife and you
know maybe his business partner but
other than that he's not telling anyone
what he's thinking he's not sharing that
with people even the people he's closest
with I mean we'll find out when everyone
else finds out so when everyone acts
like well this is what Tommy wants he's
never told anyone that you've never
heard it from his mouth that's true
you've never heard it from the people
who represent him you've just heard from
people like you and I rich that we have
our conjecture of what he wants but we
really don't know for sure what what he
wants us to get paid I mean not that I
think that that's the most important
thing because from knowing I'm the most
important thing to him is whether or not
all right so wherever he goes he wants
to be in a position where he can win
another ring you know whether that be
New England or somewhere else know but
but but at the end of the day unless you
hear from him unless you hear from Bill
all's it is is conjecture and there's
just a lot I guess a lot of empty time
to fill before then right Charlie to try
and figure out how what tendencies are
here and what people have said in the
past and how sensitive they have
in to the subject matter and and it just
leaves us all here to to speculate
wait there's there's gonna be people
that are right because everyone's
guessing something I mean I mean so
there are going to be ample people that
are writing their guests but but I think
that bills continuing to do his work I
think Tommy's continuing to do his work
I think that all the meetings of minds
once a CBA it is decided they'll have a
meeting combined they'll say here's you
know here's here's what here's the game
plan
and then Tommy is either going to say he
can come back and say well here's what I
like and if they can come to an
agreement they will and if they won't go
they'll shake hands and say thank you
for everything and move on their way
this is not going to be a this is not
going to be a cold miserable breakup or
anything like that I think they both
been around for a long time and I've
worked very well together and had huge
success and I think that this will not
be one of those ones where everyone
tells everyone to go to hell and walks
away that's not the way this lasts so we
shouldn't I personally personally hope
he ends up just staying in New England
but I don't know whether or not that
that's gonna be the witness in the play
out yeah I I I don't know I just I just
feel that maybe after 20 years everybody
wants to hear a different voice that's
just the sense I get and again you're
right Tom's not telling this to anybody
he's certainly not telling it to me
it's just what I hear and what I guess
and what I suppose and just trying to
read into the fact that we have reached
this point right I mean that the
Patriots could have put something on the
table over the last several weeks and
just didn't or we do you know the one
thing that the one thing it is cool
though rich yet really if he does if he
does go this is going to be this is
gonna be exciting because if he does go
OK one of the Patriots do instead of
their quarterback today go get a veteran
quarterback what do they do and what
happens wherever he goes that starts
this whole trickle-down effect where now
all the pieces start falling in places
the league so for this time of year to
have one guy being able to have that
type of a ripple effect I mean that that
that intrigues me I'm kind of exciting
this either way I'm kind of excited she
would have a great charlie weis few more
minutes left with the the be a ball
coach from back in the day in the NFL of
course Notre Dame right here on the Rich
Eisen show which quarterback coming out
of college would you take first you got
burrow you got tool with supposedly a
clean hip Herbert has a big upside
Jordan love anybody that you've seen
that you say that that's the that's the
guy out there well I'm a - I'm a - a fan
I mean and no one can deny the year that
Barrow had it was phenomenal and not
only did he play great but he played
great against all the good teams you
know he you know he beat all those teams
and the SEC West you know and then they
go through the tournament they roll
through that including wrong rollin over
Clemson knowing kickin that can deny the
year he had and I can understand why you
know homegrown kid state of Ohio since
he pickin I could see why they take him
I'm a - a fan you know I know I'm known
more about - uh you know my kid had been
at Alabama for a couple years one of his
assignments when he was at Alabama was
to go out to Hawaii and at the big
football camp they have out there make
sure those others colleges don't steal
them away from Alabama so I mean you
know seriously that you know imagine
that assignment you're a 21 year old kid
and Nick says don't don't screw it up
and let him go somewhere else
no pressure no pressure or anything like
that but I'm a - a fan I know I know
what everyone in Alabama thinks to him
you know especially in that office and
in Tuscaloosa and watching him play and
know what they say he has that it factor
well kevin faulk who you know very well
Charlie he's at
you and he's told Daniel Jeremiah my
colleague on NFL Network and others that
borough reminds him exactly like Brady
in terms of makeup in terms of heart in
terms of also mechanics do you see any
similarities you see that my my only
concern is one year starter that that's
my only concern you know when one one
you when you've done it for a year is
different than when you've done it for
multiple years so I I love the year the
kid had I can't argue that but Kevin who
I love one of my favorite players right
that I ever coached there's no reason
for him to say that if he didn't believe
that right okay but but I that that to
me is second-hand knowledge all's I can
go you know when my kid tells me you
know you know that the kid has has the
it factor you know then he has the it
factor what if I threw Trevor Lawrence
into the mix would you take him over
anybody else ah the kid from Clemson he
might be good he might go above all of
them but but he's not in the mix this is
fine a fun shot before I let you go I
got a couple minutes left you tell
somebody that might be out there a
millennial that's watching us we haven't
where our feeds on YouTube as well
Parcells what it was like safe for work
story for Parcells what about like they
give me a good one it's one of my first
weeks one of my first weeks on the job
we're having a staff meeting you know
earlier that day we had had a special
team segment where I was back with the
punt returners or Dave maggot marking on
their Ingram and Stephen Baker okay so
this was 1990 so Mike's webmin who's the
special teams coach he was working with
the long snapper and the punter during
this drill so he wasn't watching the
returner he was watching the long
snappers in the park so we're now on a
staff meeting and Parcells goes to sweat
room alright so rank these punt
returners for me
well sweat hadn't gotten an opportunity
to even watch
you know watch him catch him yet yeah we
haven't had a chance to watch the video
yet yeah so we were stumbling and
bumbling a little bit about you know
what the answer was so because I was
back there I said hey coach Megas
obviously first engrams English clearly
second Baker's there so porcell stops
the stops the meetings and looked down
at me at the end of the table on the
right hand side and says you've been in
the league for five minutes so why don't
you just sit there and shut the hell up
no one cares what you think so needless
to say I got humbled very quickly in my
I think you cleaned it up for me too
didn't you Charlie right you clean that
you write your assessment though correct
were you correct yeah the one you earn
your keep then you can open your mouth
but not until that's the point thanks
for the time Charlie will do this do
this again there's a lot of fun all
right take care you got it right back at
you it's been a long time since I
chatted with charlie weis right here in
the Richard